[Music]
hello everyone
so uh we are going to continue our
discussions
of the chapter on mathematical
preliminaries
and we're going to start a new topic
today uh
called coordinate transformations and
the motivation for studying this topic
can be directly linked
to what we had discussed at the very
first class of mathematical
preliminaries
so let us quickly go back to that page
that first page
and refer to
that motivation so
you see here that the same vector v
was represented referred to a coordinate
axis
x 1 x 2 x 3 in this particular form and
then alternatively the same vector v
was represented in the x 1 dash x 2 dash
x 3 dash coordinate system through this
system
what we want to find out in the
current topic that the topic that we're
going to begin today
called coordinate transformations is
what is the connection
if any between this representation and
this representation
so with this motivation let us begin our
topic
okay so first let us draw
a particular coordinate axis a set of
coordinate axis
like this so suppose
we have
these three coordinate axis
x1 x2
x3 and
suppose we have another set of
coordinate axis
let's say
x1 dash
x2 dash and
x3 dash here okay
so uh
you understand that along this x1 will
have the unit vector e1
along this x2 will have e2 and along
this x3 will have
e3 for keeping this picture
relatively clutter free i am not
explicitly denoting those unit vectors
in a similar fashion uh so this is x 1
dash so along this x 1 dash
will have a unit vector e 1 dash along
this
x 2 dash there will be e2 dash and along
this x3 dash
there will be a e3 dash so
what we want to say first of all is that
let the angle between this x1 dash
axis and this x1 axis
be denoted by some angle
and let the the cosine of that
angle be given by
a by the expression
q 1 1 so what we are saying is
the cosine of
the cosine of
the angle between x1 dash
and x1 let that be
represented by q11
at the same time you note that the angle
that x1 will make with x1 dash
that will be the same angle and the
cosine of that will again be
q11 okay
in a similar fashion the cosine of the
angle
uh that the x1 dash axis makes with the
x2 axis okay so suppose this angle the
cosine of that
that will be represented by
x1 dash comma cos of x1 dash comma
x2 that will be q12
similarly we can have the cosine
that of the of the angle that
let us say the x 2 dash axis makes with
the x 3
that will be q 2 3
and so the angle that the x the cosine
of the angle that the x3 axis makes with
the x2 dash
will also be q23
okay now uh
how can these be utilized in writing
the or in making or establishing the
connection
between these two coordinate axes so
what we'll note
is first of all the
e1 at dash
so the the unit vector along this line
along this
x one dash axis what will be that
so the magnitude of that is one
so the component of
that unit vector the e one dash unit
vector along the x
one the component of this unit vector
along the x one
mind you this is very important that
component
will be what that will just be the
cosine of this angle and that we have
already seen is nothing but q 1 1
so this will be
q 1 1 e 1 hat
in a similar fashion the angle or the or
the component
of this e1 hat
along the x2 that will be nothing but
q12
and a similar fashion the component of
the e1 dash
along e3 will be q13
so we have this relation
in a similar fashion the e2
at dash that will be
q 2 1 e 1 hat
plus q 2 2 e 2 hat
plus q 2 3 e 3 hat
and finally the e 3 hat dash
that will be q p 1 e 1 hat
plus q 3 2
e 2 hat plus q
[Music]
p3 e3 hat
okay now uh
we can represent these three relations
three these three different relations
using the using the matrix
representation
so this can be written as
e 1 hat e 2 hat
e 1 had dash e 2 hat dash and e 3 hat
dash
in the form of a column matrix
and this can be written as q 1 1 q 1
2 q13
q21 q22
q23 q31
q32 q33
multiplied with
e1 at
e2 hat e3 hat
and finally this particular matrix
representation
that can be represented in short
as in the index notation as e 1 hat dash
is equal to
so uh perhaps instead of calling it the
index notation it would be better to
call it the
the the shortened component wise
notation because
uh ideally in the pure index notation we
would not be writing these
these unit vectors themselves so
with that that understanding we write
this so
you see uh and please make sure that
uh that you verify that this is indeed
the correct form for
from this okay and this has direct
connection with uh with what we had
written uh in our previous parts of the
lecture
okay so
we have this connection between the unit
vectors in the x 1 dash x 2
x 3 axis with the with those in the x 1
x 2 x 3 axis
now what about the reverse relation so
what i mean to say is that
here i have written down three relations
where on the left hand side i have the
unit vectors e 1
hat dash e 2 hat dash and e 3 hat dash
but suppose
i want to take the component of the e
1 lying along the x 1
along the x one dash so what will be
that
that will be nothing but q one one
similarly if i take
the component of the e one along the x
two dash
what will be that so this time you have
to be a little bit careful
and note that going by our previous
convention
the q12 is the angle between
the x1 is the cosine of the angle
between x1 dash and x2
but here we are not talking about that
angle we are talking about the angle
that the x1 makes with x2 dash or
conversely
the angle that x2 dash makes with x1 so
if we go back to this convention of of
writing the queues
then the the appropriate term that we
are looking for
is not the q12 when we are talking about
this particular angle between the x1 and
the x2 dash rather it is the
q21 and finally when we want to take the
component
of the x1 along the x3 dash it is
actually the
q31 which we need so with this
understanding
let us proceed and write down in a
similar fashion as these
the e1 e2 and e3 in terms of the e1
dash e2 dash and the e3 dash and that
will do in the next page
so
we have e 1 hat is equal to
q 1 1 multiplied with
e 1 hat dash plus very importantly
it is the q 2 1 which is present here
multiplied with the e to hat dash and
the q 3
1 e 3 dash
next e 2 hat will be equal to
this time we have the q 1 2 because this
represents the cosine of the
angle that the x one dash
axis makes with the x uh two axis
okay or conversely that the x two axis
makes with the x one dash axis
so this is the right term here
for this one it's very easy this is the
q22
and this one would be the
q p2 e3 dash
and finally for the e3 what we have
is q13
e1 at dash
plus q 2
3 e 2 hat dash
plus q 3 3 e 3
dash okay and again these can be
these relations they can be together
written
as e1 at in matrix representation as
just as before
this entire matrix multiplied with
the e1 hat dash the e2 hat dash
let me write that properly e1 had dash
e2 hat
dash e3 hat dash
and this entire relation
is written as e i at
is equal to q
j i e j
hat dash so you please compare very
quickly
what we had written in the previous page
here it was
e i dash is equal to q i j e j hat
and here we have the e i hat is equal to
q
j i instead of the q i j we have the q j
i here
because the way that these angles have
have
appeared here and we have ej
hat dash here so uh
now what we are going to do is uh and
before before saying anything else let
me point out that
when we are writing these these matrix
representations or equivalently the
the the index notation and particularly
the matrix representation
so if you compare this one and this one
okay so uh
you should not have any impression that
somehow
we are we are obtaining this directly
by some kind of inverse transformation
okay
so uh what i what i mean to say is that
this is this is a matrix equation and
you can
invert uh this this this equation
these equations to obtain the e1 e to e3
in terms of this e1 hat dash into hat
dash and e3 hat dash
but in this particular case we are not
doing that
we are purely following the geometrical
arguments
to set up these axes and
they are as they they are appearing okay
so we are not
we are not doing any algebraic uh
manipulations here to
to obtain this particular form these are
purely following from the
geometrical uh considerations now
what we are going to do next is to
is to write some general vectors
uh using these
relations and through that process we'll
be able to
make the connection between how the same
vector
can be represented in the two different
coordinate systems that we have been
considering
uh and through through that
through those steps and that that
connection will be clear
okay so uh what we are going to do first
of all
is let's go to the next page
and let us write down the vector we are
interested in so let this be the v
vector and we have already seen that
this
can be written as v i
e i hat we have already seen that on the
first page of mathematical preliminaries
this is v i e i hat and that is
equivalent to in the other coordinate
system
v i dash e i hat dash
now you note that this ultimately
represents some sort of a summation
okay so borrowing the ideas from the
from the pure index notation
and noting that we are not actually uh
using the pure index notation
we can write this thing for our
convenience
as v j day p j dash
e j hat dash there is no harm in doing
that
okay there is no harm in doing that
rather you'll see that
the steps that we are going to follow
after this will become
uh quite nice quite neat and clean
because of writing like this so
what we are going to do here is uh
we note from the previous uh
from the previous page that e
i dash is equal to q i j
e j hat okay so let me write down that
in the side here we have already seen
that e i at dash
is equal to q i j
e j hat
now you see on the right hand side this
j is a repeated index
okay the the order of the tensor here
is is represented by this free index
i on the left hand side also i now
suppose i want to write e j dash
what can i do just like when i was
appearing here
the i was appearing in the first index
of q so also
i can write like this q j
and i can write it like some p
e p hat but this is just a dummy index
this p is just a dummy index
i can replace it by k i can replace it
by
m and if i can do those things i might
as well replace this by i there is no
harm here
so if i do that then q j
i e i is a form which will actually help
me
in achieving my objective here of making
the connection between the
two different representations in the two
coordinate axes
so what is that so let's consider
the fact that v i e i hat
is equal to v j dash
e j hat dash
now this e j hat dash i will use
this particular expression
the vj dash remains as it is and for the
ej hat
dash i will write it as q j
i e i at
okay
now you see on the left hand side i have
a e i hat on the right hand side i have
e i hat
so can i not write it like this that
vi is equal to
vj dash q
ji or equivalently
i can write it as
vi just to make it look a little bit
cleaner i put the qgi first
pj dash okay
so with this step i have obtained some
connection between the vi
and the vj dash
now i will consider again this relation
but now in the reverse order so
this time i'll write it like dj
at e v j e j hat dash is equal to
v i e i
now you see we have already obtained
the expression of e i in terms of the e
j hat earlier
if we go back to the previous page here
we already have
the expression of e i hat in terms of
the e j
hat dash and we are directly going to
utilize this
uh this expression so
the left hand side remains as it is
the vi remains as it is we quickly take
one more look at the expression of e
i it is q j i here
so q j i
ej at dash and again you see
both on the left hand side as well as on
the right hand side i have the presence
of the ej hat dash
so what i can write this as
is uh but there should be a this should
be
this should be a vj dash okay please
note this carefully there should be a vj
so this is equal to q
j i d i
okay now because we have too many i's
and j's here
i think it will be uh it will be useful
for our later steps
to just write this uh to replace this
dummy index i here
in terms of another letter k
all right now what can we do
you see we have obtained
the vi in terms of the vj dash
and reversely we have obtained the vj
dash
in terms of the vi okay
now what if we combine these two
okay so what we are going to do next
is to consider this relation again
so we write this again
and let me separate this part out
that there is no confusion so
i i write this again as vi is equal i
just repeat it
q j i v j
dash and here
i i utilize this particular
expression here
okay so what i obtain is
q ji so the vj dash
will become q jk
dk now
uh in the next step
what we can do is we see that on the
on the left hand side we have a vi and
on the right hand side we have a v
k so if we want we can get rid
of this of this vi or the vk
by
by writing on the left hand side
vk delta
ik so this should
give me qji so these queues remain
the same as in the previous step the vk
also remains the same so the entire
right hand side is the same as before
but on the left hand side this
substitution power
of the chronicle delta applied in
reverse this time
so uh here we have vi we have we have
applied the substitution power in
reverse now so
we have the emergence of this v k which
is also present on the right hand side
that was the motivation
so ultimately what we can do is we can
write this as
q j i q j k
is equal to delta ik
now before going forward with any
further step
uh whenever you do these kinds of tensor
algebra you must always make sure that
whatever you are obtaining as a final
step
there the order of the tenses as
represented by the free indices
as well as the what those free indices
are
they are consistent on the left hand
side and the right hand side
so on the left hand side we have j as
the dummy index so that does not matter
that is not contributing to the order of
the tensor
the order of the tensor of whatever this
entity is there on the left hand side
that is contributed by this
i and this k so there are two free
indices
they are i and k so on the left hand
side we have a tensor
of order two and on the right hand side
very consistently we have
again the presence of this i and the k
as they are on the left hand side
and this again is a tensor of order to
say so everything is nice
now you can check
that this q j i q j
k that can be written in the compact
notation
as q transpose
contracted with q itself and
this chronicle delta is nothing but the
compact notation for the identity matrix
okay so this i is nothing but
so i can just write down here in the
rough very quickly
so if you want to write down the matrix
representation of this i
it is simply the very familiar 1 0 0
0 1 0 0 0 1 matrix
the identity matrix okay so the i
uh second order tensor is nothing but
the
compact notation for this identity
matrix
and this here is a very very important
relation so you see
we have not only connected the
uh the the two under the vector
the vector representation of
let me go back to this this figure
we have not only managed to connect the
vector representation
uh in these two coordinate axes but
in the process we have also managed to
find out
that the transformation matrix q
okay so so this q is the is a
the second order tensor by itself and uh
in the matrix representation it is
referred to as the
transformation matrix so very explicitly
speaking
this is our transformation matrix here
this entire thing this three by three
matrix
so that transformation matrix uh
is uh is orthogonal okay
so that's a very important fact
so with this we are going to
conclude this part of the lecture and in
the
subsequent lecture we are going to
finish it finish up this chapter on
mathematical preliminaries with one
small but with uh but with one very
important
topic of discussion which will be again
again important
for what we discuss in the subsequent
chapters all right
thank you very much